hello in this video I'll talk about the
differences between class 1 MHC and
class 2 MHC molecules first of all when
we are talking about the differences
between them
we should start at a structural level
what are the differences between them so
at a structural level class 1 MHC has
one big alpha chain which contains of
subdomain of alpha 1 alpha 2 and alpha 3
now alpha 3 is the domain which
interacts with the t-cell co-receptor
cd8 whereas in case of class 2 MHC it
has two separate chain one chain has
alpha 1 and alpha 2 domain another chain
is beta 1 and beta 2 double here in
class 1 MHC it has a beta 2
microglobulin domain which is entirely
encoded by a very different gene from
different chromosome now if we look at
the extra crystallographic structure we
will get a lot of idea about how they
can present a peptide to the respective
cells and also how big or what type of
peptides or antigens could be presented
by each class of MHC molecule the big
difference lies in the peptide binding
groove of MHC class 1 and class 2 MHC
class 2 molecules has a bigger peptide
binding groove compared to MHC class 1
MHC class 1 MHC class one's peptide
binding group is such that the end is
kind of narrowed and closed as a result
only small or shorter peptide ranging
from a 8 to 10 amino acid length can get
accommodated in that groove and certain
anchoring residues at the C and the N
terminus can allow them to stick into
the groove properly if the peptide is
little long like 9 to 10 amino acid then
it can curve and bulge out from the
major the groove of the MHC class 1
whereas in MHC class 2 molecules it
accommodate 13 to 18 amino acid long
peptide antigens because the two side of
the group is kind of empty so the
peptides the exterior of the peptide can
hang from that so class 2 MHC molecules
have are having bigger capacity for
antigens now we talked about how these
class 1 and class 2 MHC molecules
present their antigen 2 plus 1 MHC
molecule is present in almost all the
nucleated cell they mostly present the
self antigens and alarm the immune
system not to harm them but in case of
pathogenic attacks such as a virus
attack they would also display a viral
and Pigeon along with the cells own self
antigens to the cd8 positive cytotoxic T
cells whereas the MHC class 2 molecule
displays antigens which are pathogen
derived and they display it to cytotoxic
not cytotoxic T cell they display it to
a cd8 positive helper T cell and leads
to activation of the T helper cells
which would further allow activation of
the B cells and producing antibody
against that specific antigen so there
lies the difference by which MHC class 1
and class 2 molecules differentially
present their peptide to different kind
of P cells now as a structural level at
a functional level we saw the
differences between MHC class 1 and MHC
class 2 molecules now let us look at at
a genetic level at a genomic level what
are the differences so it turns out that
plus 2 MHC s and class 1 MHC s are
actually coming from different HLA
clusters so they are also the the gene
regions are also different and last but
not the least the way MHC class 1 and
class 2 are processed and displayed on
the surface it's also very different for
example though the slide is a little bit
busy but
stay with me in class two MHC processing
the image processing starts in the ER
and the MHC molecule is totally
assembled and at that point of time
no antigen is loaded onto it instead a
chain known as HL ADM is loaded onto it
after the point of time when they are
fusing with the endosome in the endosome
the incoming pathogenic antigens are
loaded onto the groove of class two MHC
and then displayed onto the surface of
the cell whereas in case of class one
MHC the peptides that need to be
displayed on the surface of the cell is
loaded onto the class one MHC antigen
binding groove in the ER by the help of
calnexin and calreticulin chaperones
after that the MHC class 1 molecule
loaded with the peptide to be displayed
is delivered via ER Golgi transport and
then it is displayed to the surface of
the cell this is how class there is a
difference between how class 1 and class
2 MHC are processed and displayed on the
respective cell surface so here is a
quick summary of the differences between
the MHC class 1 and class 2 molecules
the major differences includes in the
structural level at the peptide binding
groove MHC class 1 has lower carrying
capacity it can carry only 8 to 10 amino
acid whereas MX applies to can carry 13
to 18 amino acids also the peptide
binding groove of both the MHC s are
differently made peptide binding groove
or MHC class 1 is made by alpha 1 and
alpha 2 subunit whereas it's different
for MHC class 2 it's made up of alpha 1
and B the one subunit we also looked at
that how MHC class 1 bound peptides are
differentially represented to Serie 8
positive cells whereas class 2 bound
peptides are displayed to
classical antigen-presenting classical
t-helper cells now also there are other
differences which includes mostly MHC
class 1 molecule displays endogenous
antigen
whereas MHC class 2 molecules always
bind to pathogen derive or exogenous
antigens so that was pretty much about
this video I hope this video was
informative if you liked this video give
it a quick thumbs up don't forget to
Like share and subscribe and do mention
how do you like my explaining
explanations in the comment section
thank you